In Neil Gaiman’s run of The Sandman, the character
Death famously says, “When the first living thing
existed, I was there waiting. When the last
living thing dies, my job will be finished.
I’ll put the chairs on the tables, turn off
the lights, and lock the universe behind me.”
And when that happens, the last creature
Death will see through the door will
likely be—as the first one was—a microbe.
Their large numbers certainly stack the
odds in their favor. But it doesn’t hurt
that many microbes have their own ways of
evading what we have deemed the inevitable.
Defying death is not as clear-cut as it
might initially seem. What we define as
immortality depends a bit on what you think it
means to die—whether it’s the loss of your own
individual self, or the loss of
something that has come to exceed you.
It also depends on what you think it means
to survive. Immortality is not a guarantee
of the microcosmos. There are predators to
contend with, and many simple forces of nature.
The tardigrade is famously resilient to these
forces, able to withstand extremes of temperature,
radiation, and pressure. They can survive these
conditions by entering cryptobiosis, desiccating
their bodies and slowing down their metabolic
rate as they become a dried out ball called a tun.
The tun state protects the tardigrade and lets
them wait out the worst for long periods of time.
And that’s part of the legend of the invincible
tardigrade, driving our speculation that they will
outlive us through any apocalypse. Researchers
have even predicted that tardigrades could survive
astronomical catastrophes like an
asteroid crashing into our planet.
But invincibility is not the same as immortality.
Tuns have been revived after 30 years of
cryptobiosis. But if we exclude the time spent
in cryptobiosis, the lifespan of most tardigrade
species ranges from a few months to a few years.
When these tardigrades are in their tun,
they’re not just protected from the
elements. They’re also protected
from senescence, the thing that we call aging.
Senescence is a combination of many deteriorations
both within cells and across them. Cells acquire
damage, and with time, that damage accumulates
and accumulates. Our bodies experience that in the
decline of different physiological functions, and
it connects to an increased mortality as we age.
When not in a tun, even the mighty tardigrade
experiences senescence. But we know of
at least one organism that does not.
Scientists studying hydra over several
years found that the mortality rates
over those years were quite low. But
even more striking, the hydra showed
no evidence of aging. You might even say
that the hydra remained forever young.
They do this by replacing their cells every 20
days, relying on three core populations of stem
cells that are themselves continuously and
indefinitely self-renewing. These stem cells
allow the hydra to reproduce asexually by
budding off, and they’re also behind the
hydra’s legendary powers of regeneration.
And these stem cells make the hydra
biologically immortal. Because its cells are
always being replaced, the hydra is able to
avoid the accumulation of damage that
other multicellular organisms experience.
The hydra doesn’t age. And so until another
force or predator intervenes, it doesn’t die.
So we have one definition of immortality that
depends on aging in multicellular organisms, but
how does that apply to single-celled creatures
that reproduce asexually? What does death mean
to a single cell that divides and divides and
divides, creating a legacy that is recursively
itself. Is it enough to just be one of thousands
(or tens of thousands) of clones to ensure that
even if you die, you still, in essence, live?
In the case of the paramecium, no.
As each paramecium divides, it ages. And it will
continue to do so with each division. With damage
accumulating in its DNA, the paramecium will
start to divide more slowly, and eventually
the clonal daughter cells will die off.
However, they can avoid this fate
through conjugation, the protist equivalent of
sex. This act is its own sort of rejuvenation,
rewinding the clock for the paramecium.
Scientists have argued that senescence
originated with protists like the paramecium.
But there are signs that some bacteria experience
aging too. They just forestall the effects of an
aging population by dividing asymmetrically. With
each split, one daughter cell will acquire more
damage than the other. And so with each division,
one cell will rejuvenate while the other
will age. The longevity of the group
is thus built on creating differences
between the seemingly identical individuals.
How does this fit in with our vision of
immortality? It’s hard to know. At this point,
the question of whether we should consider
a flask of bacteria immortal starts to feel
like a matter of semantics. It’s informed as much
by personal and philosophical ideas as it is by
biological ones. But of course, some of the most
interesting questions of science and philosophy
boil down to issues of semantics. These aren’t
just questions of how the world exists, but also
of how we see the world, how we describe
it to each other, how we imagine it.
For millennia, we’ve been constructing
immortals as part of our religions
and myths to understand the world around
us. In the stories we tell, these immortals
dictate our lives in invisible ways, and
they defy the thing we do not want to face.
But microbes don’t have the same grandiosity as
the mythical figures we create. They don’t need
to. The hydra may be biologically immortal,
but at the end of the day, it’s a tube with
arms. And a lack of senescence aside, if a
predator is able to make the hydra its prey,
the hydra is still quite capable of dying.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us
as we explore the unseen world that surrounds
us. And thank you especially to all these
people. Our patrons on Patreon who make
it possible for us to make this show.
If you want to see more from our
master of microscopes james Weiss,
you can check out Jam & Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us,
there’s always a subscribe button somewhere nearby